hello everyone it's Jake and welcome
back to another Elden ring lore hunting
video today I wanted to talk about my
dream theory video and expand on it a
bit more from what I can tell you guys
really seem to enjoy this Theory but
there were some that seemed to think
that it would be to the detriment of the
overall story if it went that route in
Shadow of the earth tree obviously I'd
encourage you to go watch it so you have
a baseline on what the theory is but let
me break it down here real quick
essentially I believe that we are
already in a dream and we will be
waiting piing up from it in the DLC
specifically mola's dream or nightmare
depending on your outlook I think it's
possible that we as the character were
created by Micha to wake him up or it's
possible that we are Mika and need to
wake ourselves up from it in order to
well that's what I'm not sure of yet the
easiest theory on why we'd want to wake
up from this dream is so that we can
stop Godwin from taking over the her
tree and the lands between and also Moog
from doing whatever the heck he's doing
with micha's body this is all in the
basis of the shadow of the UR Trey image
that the UR Trey is being strangled by
Godwin's death blight I believe in the
DLC will have the choice to either let
Godwin continue his deadly influence or
we will stop him and have ourselves or
Micha plant a new tree to replace the
old like micha's Halo tree so what some
people didn't like about this theory is
that they felt it would be a copout like
some TV shows or movies do to not even
try on an ending suggesting that the
whole thing wasn't real never happened
and ultimately doesn't matter anymore I
understand this but it isn't really what
I meant I tried explaining in the first
video that the content and events of
Dreams and Nightmares can only be
created from things places and people
that the dreamer has seen or experienced
in real life the brain can't just make
up random people or events it has to be
based on something the dreamer has seen
before this would mean that if the dream
theory turned out to be true than all of
the events people and experiences we
play through the game would have been
based on things at least Micha has seen
or experienced in the past now all of
those things could be exaggerated or
blown out of proportion in a dream but
they'd have to be based on something
Concrete in one way or another meaning
it definitely wouldn't just be the easy
copout ending if it's just a dream and
none of it matters anymore we'd still
have to piece together everything on
what it means within the dream and what
it really means in the real world
the real lands between from software has
shown they like working with the idea of
Dreams in other worldly areas in pretty
much all of their games in one way or
another so I wouldn't put it past them
to think in a dreamlike or nightmarish
way I don't like talking about cut
content much because well it was cut for
a reason they didn't intend for the
player to ever see it which means it was
never intended to be inferred within the
grand scheme of the story however it
does mean that they did at one point
think it would would work or make sense
at least enough to coat it within the
game before removing it there's one
piece of cut dialogue found by data
miners just a few months after the
release of the game that could
potentially be from Micha that I'd like
to share young seedling young seedling
return to the bosom of Earth but
remember well Thou Art mine so shall I
give of myself this is for thee mine
abundance my drop of dew quench thy
thirst throughout thy frame
Blossom and burgon time and again grow
larger stronger until the day cometh
when thou can share in my dream Elden
ring oh Elden ring beget order most
elegant from my tender rever if thou
covet us the throne impress my vision
upon thine heart in the new world of thy
making all things will flourish whether
graceful or malign I mean that sounds
pretty close to what the dream theory is
suggesting he created us us gave us
every opportunity to succeed and grow
stronger then one day we can share in
his dream if we become Elden Lord he
wants us to create a new world with him
a world that we decide whether graceful
or malign which represents all of the
potential endings again this is cut
content so I don't want to talk about it
too much but I thought it would be
useful here to at least discuss a lot of
comments I received on the original
video were like this one from D major
that said if the land between we see and
game is a part of the dream it kind of
makes the whole story a lot less
interesting to me it makes everything
that happens far less important and
impactful I've always seen it as
somewhere that exists somewhere between
life and death I.E the lands between
calleded up by Zayn saying yes I have a
feeling the realm will enter will be a
dream so like I said earlier I
personally don't think that everything
being a dream would make the story less
impactful or important based on
everything I've already said they would
have have to be based on real world
events and characters but yes they could
be mixed in weird ways within the dream
or exaggerated we could only piece the
facts together based on what's real and
what would be a dream which is why I
think it would be amazing and also
likely that we'll be able to go in and
out of this dream at will when the DLC
releases that's how all of from
software's DLCs have been in the past
they're completely separate areas that
you can leave and return to whenever you
want it definitely won't be like select
a new save called shadow of the UR tree
in the main menu it'll be more
complicated than that and will likely
require players to reach a certain
section in the game to unlock even after
purchasing the DLC I think this will
likely lead to some upset new players
who haven't experienced a from software
DLC before and how it really works but I
personally love that you have to go find
it it makes it that much more
interesting to me but I've always found
the main story to make sense but the
little details within the story story
just don't add up to me from time to
time especially in regards to Micha
Godwin and queen America along with the
Knight of black knives like I said in
the original video the L between has
always felt like a weird mix of various
timelines major events and landmarks all
mashed together into one Purgatory type
landscape that isn't really a real place
in what way obviously I'm not sure
everything I suggest is a theory I pride
myself on these theories and thinking
outside the Box aside from the facts we
can get from all of the item
descriptions I think that's What
Separates Me from the other amazing
Elden ring creators I like to think of
what could be not what factually is it's
more fun in my eyes and leads to more
Community discussions than what anyone
could figure out by reading every item
description someone also mentioned that
it's important to point out that based
on what Gideon can tell us about Mika it
was mola's disappearance that caused
Queen America's sorrow ultimately
leading to her decision to shattered the
Elden ring and therefore starting the
shattering War along with the Knight of
black knives that killed her first son
Godwin the golden ah so the secret
medallions LED you to the land of the
haly tree I'd expect to find melenia
there she who fought ran to a standstill
well if the Scarlet rot hasn't eaten her
away completely but with the hay trees
as it is I suppose mola must already be
ah my
apologies lost myself for a moment there
so the halic tree now but a husk I heard
speculation Nia embedded himself in the
helic tree but before he could finish
someone cut the tree open and absconded
with his infant form
indeed it seems those words held weit
how vexing that they all know didn't
have the full story perhaps the queen
sorrow was
justified ah my
apologies lost myself for a moment there
so if Gideon had already heard a rumor
that Mika had been removed from the Halo
tree then he just assumed that mola must
have been dead along with the Halo tree
however when we returned to Gideon with
the information that Mika is in mn's
Palace Gideon seemed surprised to hear
that the rumors he heard were at least
somewhat true but that Micha had not yet
died Gideon will also reward you with
the incantation Lord's Divine
fortification which reads Gideon gained
true knowledge after his long exchange
with the two fingers discovering all had
been broken long ago that the trembling
fingers bent with age and the urry
itself were no exception this all brings
up the discussion we've been having that
not all is what it seems to be and that
all details are required to unravel the
full story what is true and what isn't
what is real reality and what is just
fabrication what really was the final
straw for Queen America to do what she
did another great comment that I
received that I'll end this video on
today was from nario who said something
I think that might explain the feeling
of the lands between being off not real
might be that it's a condensed form of
what used to be a much larger and more
coherent continent I believe that much
like Dark Souls 3s is all over the world
is converging at lothric I idea is
similarly happening this really isn't
something I had considered that the
lands between didn't become what it was
until the shattering meaning the
shattering had caused the land to break
away from the overall continent it was
originally attached to and now can only
be accessed by crossing the fog still
don't know 100% what that means but it
could be in reference to Crossing into
another realm entirely or there's just
literal fog in the ocean around the
lands between which is entirely possible
of course we can see wreck ships in some
of the areas of the ocean so they must
be coming from somewhere right all in
all I love discussing this Theory and it
makes me want to start doing my lore
hunting live streams that I used to do
here on the channel so give the video a
like and let me know if that's something
you guys would want to see again I'm
growing increasingly excited as we get
closer to the game awards where I
believe we will get a trailer for shadow
of the UR Trey or from software will
troll us and release it the day after
which honestly would be pretty funny
thanks for watching and I'll see you all
in the next video which will'll be going
over all of the things we are still
confused about in regards to the story
of Elden ring take care well I wonder
what comes next if he continues his
Slumber within the Cocoon all would be
well but perhaps it would be safer to
destroy it Nicola is the one thing that
remains a mystery to
me